يكشف جميع الحلفاء الغربيين القلقين بشأن
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني الجديد لشبكة سي إن إن
أن الحلفاء
يتلقون تحديثات مثيرة للقلق من
Battleground، على وجه التحديد حول
قدرة القوات الأوكرانية على استعادة السيطرة على
مناطق كبيرة.
يقول مسؤول أمريكي كبير إن الهجوم المضاد
يسير بشكل أصعب وأبطأ مما
قد يرغب أي شخص في أوكرانيا  كما أن لديه
نافذة محدودة لدفع المسؤولين إلى الأمام ليقولوا
ما إذا كان من
المتوقع أن تتفاقم الظروف مع اقتراب الخريف
، وهذا بالطبع تغيير ملحوظ
عن الخطاب المتفائل الذي
سمعناه في بداية الهجوم، وانضم إلى
جيم شوتر، رئيس CNN للمراسلين الأمنيين الأمريكيين.
نحن الآن من واشنطن العاصمة
مع تقاريره، جيم، هذا
تطور مهم للغاية وإلقاء نظرة ثاقبة
على تفكير
المسؤولين والحلفاء الغربيين، ما هي
المفاجأة أو خيبة الأمل الفعلية هنا
على وجه التحديد لأننا كنا نعلم أن هذا
الهجوم المضاد سيكون مرهقًا، وهو
في الأساس  حرب الاستنزاف، ما هو
العنصر الذي أثير بالنسبة لك،
إنه عدد من الأشياء حقًا بيانكا
وأنا أسمع تقييمات مماثلة تمامًا
هنا في الولايات المتحدة وفي
أوروبا وهذا ينطبق على
المسؤولين العسكريين والدبلوماسيين وكذلك المشرعين،
وبعضها كان متوقعًا
خطوط دفاع روسية  من الصعب اختراقها،
فهي متعددة الطبقات، ومغطاة
بعشرات الآلاف من العقول، وقد
تكبدوا عندما حاولوا
اختراق تلك الخطوط خسائر مدمرة
تكبدتها القوات الأوكرانية
ونتيجة لذلك قاموا بسحب بعض
تلك الخطوط  عادت الوحدات لأنها تريد
تقليل تلك الخسائر بشكل مفهوم ولكنها
أيضًا مشكلات طويلة المدى. هنا
بعض الانتقادات لقصر
التدريب الذي كان ممكنًا لبعض
هذه الوحدات الأوكرانية خاصة أنها
تتلقى
أنظمة أسلحة غربية متقدمة جديدة مثل
الفهد الألماني  في بعض الحالات، قيل لي إن
حوالي ثمانية أسابيع من التدريب والصورة الكبيرة هي أن
التحدي المتمثل في تحويل
الوحدات إلى ألوية ميكانيكية حقًا في
فترة زمنية قصيرة هو أمر يصعب
القيام به وتحقيق النجاح ونحن
نرى النتائج  من ذلك، مع هذا
ذهابًا وإيابًا على طول
الخطوط الأمامية، كسب بعض الأراضي في بعض
المناطق ولكن بالتأكيد ليس إلى الدرجة
التي كنا نأملها وقد أخبرني
مسؤولو الإدارة أيضًا أن
خيبة الأمل هذه تنطبق على
المسؤولين الغربيين ولكن أيضًا على الولايات المتحدة.  الأوكرانيون
أنفسهم لم يفقدوا الأمل
ولكن كما ذكرت بيانكا فإن
ضغط الوقت حقيقي، فالسقوط قادم
ستزداد ظروف القتال الجوية سوءًا وهناك
أيضًا
ضغوط سياسية هنا وفي أوروبا من أجل
النجاح والنجاح بسرعة
أجنبية